20:18 is shaping up to feature a bumper
crop of films capable of winning over
the hearts of audiences and critics
alike using craftsmanship and artistry
along with the usual loads of action and
spectacle from quirky historical
comedies to unexpectedly brilliant
animated offerings these are the very
best films 2018 has to offer so far
thoroughbreds young actress anya taylor
joy has been busy carving out a niche
for herself as a modern-day scream queen
earning starring roles and critically
acclaimed fright flicks the witch and
split in just the last few years so it's
no surprise first-time writer director
Corey Finley recruited her for his debut
black comedy thriller thoroughbreds and
with the help of his clockwork script
and understated tension generating
direction he was able to score a winner
on his first outing the plot follows a
pair of reuniting friends as they
schemed to assassinate one stepfather
and critics were impressed with Finley's
ability to bring a classical feel to the
film which had a nice balance of
darkness and humor about it the
technique holy Sh after thoroughbreds
it's clear a tour Corey Finley will be
one to watch annihilation writer
director Alex Garland has made a name
for himself with dark cerebral sci-fi
thrillers that aim for a realm beyond
simple entertainment after pinning the
screenplays for such well-received
flicks as 28 days later and Dredd he
made his directorial debut in 2015 with
ex machina which earned him his first
Academy Award nomination and a whole lot
of interest in what would come next his
sophomore feature annihilation proved
that the buzz surrounding his first
outing was not a fluke adapted from jeff
van der Meers 2014 novel the
mind-blowing genre subverting story
makes good use of Garland's talent for
atmosphere not to mention it's roundly
excellent cast headed up by Natalie
Portman and featuring Tessa Thompson
Oscar Isaac and Jennifer Jason Leigh
annihilation follows a team of
scientists who dare to explore the
shimmer an anomalous area in which the
very concept of reality doesn't seem to
apply the film received massive praise
for its stunning visuals and sweeping
metaphors and
was celebrated for being a film that
challenged expectations that left
viewers perplexed and still massively
entertained I love dogs animated films
don't get much quirkier than I love dogs
a stop-motion feature from the king of
cinematic work Wes Anderson the film
follows a young Japanese boy in a
near-future dystopia on the hunt for his
dog who along with all other dogs has
been quarantined on an island after an
outbreak of disease the film features
voice performances by Bryan Cranston
Edie Norton Frances McDormand Harvey
Keitel Tilda Swinton and Yoko Ono just
to name a few apart from a few stray
dissenters the reviewers were generally
won over by the phenomenal work of the
cast and by the film's meticulous
artistry
[Music]
even if Anderson's works aren't
necessarily your cup of tea Isle of Dogs
is a must watch if for no other reason
than the witness Bryan Cranston
channeling Walter White and dog for love
Simon whether or not it was any good
love Simon was destined to be important
since it was the first major studio
Hollywood film to focus on a gay team
bromance
fortunately director Greg Berlanti
delivered a film that's notable for more
than just that reason it's also a funny
disarmingly sweet rom-com that had
audiences bawling and laughing out loud
working from a 2015 why a novel the
script is populated with strongly drawn
characters and actor Nick Robinson earns
praise for his leading role among a cast
that includes Jennifer Garner Josh
Duhamel and Alexandra Shipp the film has
been noted for its modern soundtrack
diverse cast an uplifting feel-good
storyline
journey's end this 90 year old world war
one story about British officers pinned
down in a dugout over several days has
been brought to the screen many times
over
but while journey's end might not seem
like the kind of movie that might
interest modern audiences director saul
dibb and screenwriters simon read along
with an amazing cast have crafted it
into a meditation on war and death that
feels surprisingly timely asa
butterfield stars as rally a young
officer under the command of sam claflin
alcoholic and unstable captain
as the soldier grapples with what it
means to follow orders under the specter
of near certain doom
plans performance was widely praised as
was that a Paul Bettany as a
mild-mannered officer who exhibits grace
under pressure
the film's period production design was
also deemed excellent as was dibs
command of mood and atmosphere it might
be a movie we've seen plenty of before
but journey's end is still as riveting
today as it was in its original
incarnation the death of Stalin Scottish
writer director Armando Iannucci is
perhaps best known stateside for his
work on the HBO series veep and he's
taken that penchant for political satire
to a whole new realm with the death of
Stalin this adaptation of a French
graphic novel provides an inside look at
the chaos humour and horror surrounding
the demise of the Russian dictator it
may seem like an unlikely subject for a
farce but the pitch black comedy has
been garnering the kind of eye popping
reviews normally reserved for prestige
pictures with some reviewers labeling it
a masterpiece featuring a stellar
international cast which includes Steve
Buscemi as nikita khrushchev Michael
Palin as the title tyrant the ambitious
film hit the sweet spot with critics who
praised it for being surprisingly timely
and whip-smart a quiet place John
Krasinski might be best known for his
comedic timing in the office but he's
proven himself to be much more than just
quick-witted thanks to his directorial
debut of the unnerving original horror
film a quiet place directing from a
screenplay by the writing team of Scott
back and brian woods
Krasinski stars alongside his real-life
wife Emily Blunt in the tale of a family
plagued by mysterious creatures witch
hunt using sound forcing their family
into a tense and silent existence the
film has been widely praised for its
daring conceptual framework and the
cast's creative and strong performances
most importantly the film is searingly
bleak and maddeningly scary
so even beyond its pure ambition the
movie is a treat for horror junkies of
all stripes black panther
after 10 years of blockbuster features
it's no surprise that Marvel Studios is
still churning out quality superhero
movies but black panther took things to
a new level altogether director Ryan
Coogler joined forces with writing
partner Joe Robert Cole to create a
story that would star chadwick boseman
in the lead managed to surpass even the
highest creative expectations and
stunned even the most optimistic
box-office watchers with its massive
ticket sales the film has been heralded
for its importance to black audiences
and offering a representative hero and
celebrating African culture and on top
of that the story structure was
astonishingly good Black Panther
explores themes of alienation and lost
more effectively than a comic book film
has any right to particularly by way of
Michael B Jordans conflicted villain
Erik kill monger Stevens who has been
cited as the emcee used best villain
ever
thanks largely to Jordans towering
performance Paddington - based on the
beloved children's character the first
Paddington film was a surprise critical
darling and a moderate hit at the box
office its success made a follow-up
inevitable but Paddington - does not
suffer the sequel slump thus far the
film has not earned a single negative
review which gives it the rare
distinction of a 100% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes some reviewers couldn't help
but marvel at the fact that the film
outdid even its formidable predecessor
with the talented Ben Whishaw reprising
the title role alongside an
appropriately British cast that includes
Hugh Grant and many many disguises
Paddington - ramps up the whimsy
Adventure and earnestness of the
original and with comparable box office
returns a third installment is all but
assured Avengers infinity war even the
eye-popping box office success of Black
Panther was only a warm-up act for
Avengers infinity war which has
shattered his many box-office records as
it did hearts as the first part of the
culmination of Marvel's three phase mega
arc the powerful Infinity stones are
collected by the mad Titan Thanos with
the goal of eradicating half of all life
in the universe infinity war brought
together nearly every important
character introduced in the MCU thus far
and fans responded by putting up the
kind of box office numbers which made it
one of the top worldwide hits of all
time while the movie didn't earn the
widespread critical adoration enjoyed by
Black Panther positive reviews
recognized it as a singularly Herculean
feat of storytelling one which takes
time to deliver meaningful arcs for
characters we've come to know and love
over the years and notably for its
villain Josh Brolin's motion capture
performances Thanos moved some critics
to declare the mad Titan the emcee used
best villain ever and especially given
the film's amazingly dark cliffhanger
ending the only one to ever pose a true
threat to Earth's Mightiest Heroes said
ending was a sticking point for some
reviewers who dubbed it a half movie but
perhaps their tomb will change when the
as yet untitled Avengers 4 debuts in May
of next year
Tulley jason reitman is a man who knows
his way around thoughtful engaging
comedy the director of hits such as
thank you for smoking Juno and up in the
air returned in 2018 with Tulley which
reunited him with screenwriter Diablo
Cody with her famously quippy dialogue
the story centers on Charlize Theron
'he's overburdened mother figure who
forms an unexpected bond with her
unusual nanny played by Mackenzie Davis
while even positive reviews were quick
to point out the screenplays contrivance
'as critics were uniformly won over by
another outstanding performance from
Ferren whose comedic chops in chemistry
with davis carried the film even
negative reviews had to give the actress
credit for her passion and skill and
most reviewers agreed that Tully was a
welcome return for the Dream Team of
Cody and Wright met while the film may
not have burned up the box office it
seems like a candidate for a strong
second life once released a video
Deadpool to fans of Ryan Reynolds Merc
with a mouth eagerly awaited the sequel
to 2016 s ridiculously huge
comparatively low-budget r-rated hit
Deadpool and Reynolds along with
incoming director david leitch didn't
disappoint you know you're a lot taller
in the shut up you'll hold those who
were even vaguely familiar with the
original knew what they could expect in
terms of insane action and over-the-top
vulgarity particularly with the
introduction of the time-traveling
cyborg cable but many of them weren't
ready for the surprising amount of
character building and emotion brought
along this time around
zaz e beats and josh brolin both arrived
as a median fan favorites and Deadpool's
assembly of the mutant superhero team
x-force is set to give the new series a
stronger foothold in franchise land and
an emotional payoff that surpasses its
predecessor it's the rare sequel that
lives up to let alone surpasses the
original but some critics are calling
Deadpool to a cut above the phenomenal
first run actually that may have been me
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]